what's going on here in 1994 Disney
expanded its enterprise and started
creating tons of sequels some of these
were more successful than others but
many have since been forgotten about we
found 10 Disney sequels that you
probably haven't thought about in ages
keep watching to find out which classic
Disney movie has a wild and unexpected
sequel he was hand chosen by scar a lion
isn't primarily about a princess but it
is one of Disney's most popular movies
and the second Aladdin film is one of
the most popular Disney sequels ever
some fans think it's even better than
the original return of Jafar takes place
a year after the first movie much of the
original cast returned but Robin
Williams couldn't voice the genie this
movie set up an animated series called
Aladdin but then Disney made a third
lesser known sequel Aladdin and the King
of Thieves this time Robin Williams
reprised his role
the infamous 40 thieves are causing
problems in Agrabah Aladdin finds out
that his father is Kassim the King of
Thieves he's after a magical item called
the hand of Midas the hand turns
anything it touches to gold in the end
Kassim realizes his son is the ultimate
treasure some might even call him a
diamond in the rough he goes off with
Iago at the end without getting caught
for his crimes
oh and jasmine and Aladdin finally tie
the knot Disney has recently revealed
that there will be a sequel to the
live-action Aladdin but it's not the
return of Jafar it's possible that this
movie will pull elements from both of
the animated sequels it's wretched thing
almost costs me the ultimate treasure
it's you son lilo and stitch is one of
the cutest and most underrated Disney
movies of all time stitches the adorable
alien with anger management issues who
gets adopted by the troubled girl lilo
she hopes saves stitch and they both
help each other heal lilo and Stitch got
a few sequels and a spin-off series you
might remember Stitch the movie that's
where we get to meet the others 625
experiments Stitch the movie led to the
successful spin-off TV series lilo and
Stitch but before the movie there
was another sequel called lilo and
stitch to stitch has a glitch stitches
destructive outbursts return and he's in
danger of running out of energy for good
circuits will burn themselves out
plus he and Leo are at odds because he
has hurted her chances of being in a
hula contest eventually they save stitch
and come together again it didn't do as
well as the next sequel there was
another movie made in 2006 - Leroy and
stitched revolving around stitches evil
twin while exploring Gant whose mighty
revenge this TV movie wrapped up the
franchise and served as the series
finale Disney's 1981 film the Fox and
the Hound is one of these saddest
animated films ever it tells the story
of a hunting dog named copper and a fox
named Todd the two become best friends
but they can't stay friends because
copper is supposed to hunt foxes it may
have been a tearjerker but when it was
released it was Disney's most expensive
film yet times sure have changed
in 2006 Disney went back to the story of
Todd and copper with a direct-to-dvd
film the Fox and the Hound 2 features
the voices of Rebecca McIntyre and
Patrick Swayze as two stray dogs in a
band the story takes place during the
events of the Fox and the Hound Todd and
Cooper are still young cups copper
considers becoming a stray and joining
up with the band it's a random little
story that critics agreed wasn't
terrible or great what just happened
I'll tell you what happened you're good
at something Atlantis the lost Empire is
an action-packed of Disney movie but
it's often underrated at the end of the
movie milo chooses to stay in Atlantis
with Keira a couple of years later
Disney released a directed video sequel
called Atlantis Milo's return the
Explorers return to Atlantis to ask for
Milo and Kitty's help fighting a monster
called the Kraken the to rejoin the
Martin world to save everyone
Keira realizes that there are tons of
Atlantean war machines in the world that
could cause problems fire did not fall
from the sky in Atlantis like it does
here
honestly the movie title is a misnomer
it's more of kidís story than Milo's in
the end she realizes that the crystal
that powers Atlantis can help the world
Atlantis emerges from the sea the movie
did not do well at all because of that
Disney scrapped its plans for a TV show
called team Atlantis this show would
have featured the characters fighting
all sorts of mythical creatures we are
totally bummed that the show never
happened the world was never the same
after that day when it comes to sad
Disney movies bambi takes the cake every
single time poor Bambi loses his mother
to hunters then his entire forest is
destroyed by a wild fire we get
teary-eyed just thinking about it
Bambi takes on his father's title great
prince of the forest in the movie in
2006 Disney decided to make us cry all
over again
they released Bambi 2 which is sometimes
called Bambi and the great prince of the
forest the distance makes it easier to
spot danger but it's not a true sequel
we don't find out what happens to
everyone after the forest fire instead
it's about what happens after Bambi's
mom passes away it's a
his relationship with his father the
original great prince of the forest we
learn a lot more about Bambi's
mysterious dad the best part is Patrick
Stewart voices the great friends
the reviews are mixed but it does have a
50% rating on Rotten Tomatoes
that's pretty high for a Disney sequel
when it comes to the original Disney
characters goofy is almost as popular as
the mouse himself in the early 1990s
goofy was the star of his own show
called the goof troop he was the single
father to a boy named max in 1995 they
got their own film goofy and his teenage
son now have a complicated relationship
but they bond over a road trip a goofy
movie didn't do great at the box office
and the reviews weren't very good living
but five years later Disney released a
video sequel an extremely goofy movie
was actually better received than the
first one it even went some awards in
this movie max is off at college goofy
accidentally causes an explosion at work
and loses his job he's told that he
needs a college degree to get another
job so he enrolls at Max's University
and well shenanigans ensue which classic
Disney movie has a crazy time-traveling
sequel keep watching to find out The
Lion King is one of the most popular and
beloved Disney films of all time and we
find out even more about Simba in the
sequel The Lion King - Simba's pride
this movie follows Simba's daughter
Kiara who is in love with a lion from an
outcast at rival pride it's one of the
best Disney sequels ever and it received
some pretty good reviews - our place is
with our pride but did you know there is
another sequel The Lion King
one-and-a-half was released directly to
video in 2004 sometimes called The Lion
King 3 Hakuna Matata
the movie tells the story of The Lion
King from a new perspective Timon and
Pumbaa tell their version of the story
even though the movie came out ten years
after the original most of the cast
reprised their roles critics loved the
sequel even more than Lion King -
living in the past we need a new bottom
now that the live-action remake of Mulan
has become a reality we had to include
the animated sequel to the original
Mulan 2 is widely considered to be one
of the worst animated sequels Mulan and
li Shang are engaged and moo shu finds
out he'll lose his job as Mullins
Guardium Mulan will be part of Chang's
family so his ancestors and guardians
will become hers Eddie Murphy did not
reprise his role as Mu Shu and it just
wasn't the same moo shu sets out to
sabotage Mulan and Shang marriage um
something wrong
I heard you Mulan every word while they
escorts three princesses to be Wed these
marriages will supposedly unite China mu
shu is really a jerk in this movie but
Mulan forgives him but things don't end
well for Shang Mulan offers to marry one
of the princess so that the princesses
don't have to marry men that they don't
love but Shang survives his fall and
shows up just in time their marriage
saves China bringing honor to them all
then Shang unites the family simple and
the little dragon gets to keep his job
Mulan - has an abysmal zero percent
rating on Rotten Tomatoes we sure hope
the movie is as good as the first one
and doesn't go the way of the sequel if
I'm driana tousle The Hunchback of Notre
Dom is one of Disney's darkest films
Quasimodo is a deformed man who is
hidden away to ring the bells of Notre
Dom the film deals with the mistreatment
of the Romani people at the hands of the
government during this time it's not one
of Disney's most popular movies by any
stretch but they made a sequel anyway
The Hunchback of Notre Dom - the secret
of the Bell takes place seven years
later Quasimodo is still the bellringer
but he is now accepted by the citizens
of Paris he's lucky to have a good
friend like you
Esmeralda and Phoebus are married with a
son a circus comes to town and it is run
by a criminal mastermind he plans to
steal one of the bells of Notre Dame
Quasimodo falls in love with a circus
performer named Madeleine the criminal
uses madellaine
Esmeralda's son Zephyr to steal the Bell
Quasimodo and Esmeralda rescue them and
the Bell just in time for the big
festival the sequel did not do well with
critics and most fans were disappointed
Cinderella is one of the earliest Disney
Princess movies and it is still loved by
fans Disney made a sequel over 50 years
later called Cinderella - dreams come
true Cinderella gets used to life as a
princess jack the mouse becomes human
and Anastasia one of the stepsisters has
a Redemption arc the DVD sold a lot of
copies but the movie was terribly
received by critics nevertheless Disney
tried again
Cinderella 3 a twist in time appears to
take place before Anastasia's Redemption
but the timeline isn't exactly clear
some of the events make it seem like the
other movie didn't happen the evil
stepmother gets her hands on fairy
godmothers wand she goes back in time
and makes the glass slipper fit
Anastasia
she banishes Cinderella to the New World
Jack and Gus tell the Prince the truth
and he saves Cinderella eventually Lady
Tremaine and Drizella are turned into
toads and later into humans wearing
Cinderella's ragged clothes it's a wild
ride but it did much better than
Cinderella to magnificent a no one knows
except us what's your favorite Disney
sequel let us know in the comments mom
would be so proud of you thanks for
watching give this video a big thumbs up
and don't freak to subscribe to the
things see you next time
you